thank you for talking to me about this
it definitely seems like some pretty
heavy and intense material to take on
and i'm curious when you read the script
and started to get a feel for this story
in this world what most spoke to you
were there specific aspects of the story
or was it something about your character
that you hadn't gotten to do before that
you were excited about
it
i'll jump in um yeah i mean i was always
pretty interested in the uh prison
as an industry concept
um and towns that had uh
you know multiple prisons in them and
then
taking over the town definitely taking
over the moody towns of the whole town
at all city fields of prison i'd watched
several documentaries about it you know
before
this came along my way at all so i was
definitely intrigued and um
[Music]
the script itself was you know a tight
crime thriller set within that world um
and there was a good character in there
which was really being teased in season
one or it's quite central to the story
but you don't see
too much of milo kind of straight off um
which is always good so i kind of like
that you know um
unless you you show you know show all
your hands straight off um
so that's that's me i mean for me it was
i i all i got seven was the pilot and uh
and episode two and as you know if
you've seen those two it's uh i'm really
not not in it i had a little character
description but i got the sides for
three scenes from from other episodes
and um
i i just hadn't read anything like it i
had a netflix film i had two amazon
series and i dropped them all for this
because and i just kept taking the risk
after this because taylor because i
wanted to work with him so bad and i and
i had so much love for these scripts and
i actually didn't get to read them until
i i think i was flying to texas to meet
him and i got sent them then by which
point i was already heavily invested in
the project but it was just the writing
and this um and what taylor does really
well is even though
jeremy is the lead um and very centric
to the storyline taylor creates
characters with so much depth and the
arc for my character was really
something special that i didn't have in
in any of the other roles um
and he just writes so well for every
single character there's so much thought
behind it and i i think that's very rare
in um
in scripts when it's not the lead you
know
yeah and they're not they're not and
those characters that you're talking
about they're not overexplained your
backstory isn't loaded on to you
you assume it's there once you start
assuming it it's kind of becomes a lot
more interesting you know it's better
about you know not being told
um so the all the characters all the
even the minor characters uh not even
the minor characters including the minor
characters are all uh very well drawn
because they have to be
yeah i think it's so interesting because
these characters all like from the
instant we meet all of them they all
feel very
complex and like they have these big
backstories but
we don't know that about them we don't
know that backstory yet we just really
learn it as the episodes progress
when you play such complex characters
with seemingly endless layers to them
how challenging is that to figure out
does it feel like there's just more
under every layer that you peel back
i think it's less of a challenge and
more and more fun that you have because
you're always filling in the gaps as an
actor of what's not on the page and and
what makes sense to you to fit to fit
what is on the page and i think it's
just it's fun to explore that and um
and and have so much to play with you
know as an actor it's better to have
more
more there and and and more information
and choose to do with it what you want
and um
and that's really all you can hope for
isn't that for me is that for me as an
actor anyway it's uh
it's what you want with a script
yeah and if it's well drawn and uh well
structured even if you don't know what
to do what to say you know the words if
you just trust in the words it'll do it
for you and trust in the pictures you
know
um that's a very basic way
it's like the more the more you do in
prep the less you can just let the more
you can let it go when you get on set
and play with it and uh
yeah i mean for me as an actual the last
thing i think about is the lines it's
like i think about everything else in
between and then the lines come a little
bit easier because you understand why
you're saying them
um
but
yeah it's i mean the role itself was a
challenge but the the whole process of
what taylor gave us was um
wasn't was just the best
aiden are there tricks for
playing a character who you know we hear
about this guy so it seems like he's
supposed to be someone that we should at
least be nervous about so are there
tricks for being menacing and dangerous
and scary as a figure when you're
playing someone in prison
well you know no the thing is like i
guess it goes back to what i was just
saying you know
if you don't really see what this guy
does or you know see him in action or
just see him or glimpses of him from
from time to time you know you kind of
if you believe what the other people are
saying
um if that seems truthful well then you
believe that he does these things so
there's not really much you can do i
mean if if you're just sitting there in
your cell and people are talking about
you that's all you have to do you know
i think the trick is to not try and do
too much and not try and um
you know show how bad you are and how
evil you are because you don't need to
emma what's it like to be a woman in
this world as a character and what's it
like to be a woman on this show as an
actor because i think just
the the women in this are so interesting
the women are very interesting i do
think taylor's written me a wonderful
role and um look it was it was it was a
it was a male dominant set and um but
all the creatives and all the people
that were involved made me feel so safe
particularly one of our producers is
michael friedman and he kind of just
went above and beyond to make sure that
i felt safe and comfortable and there's
one day that i came to set where there's
a particularly really hard scene and i
show up and i'm like are we rolling why
is it so quiet and they're like this is
for you today like this is you know they
they set up a really private area with a
tent with like a heater in there and a
dressing table and snacks and a couch
and cushions and a carpet and they just
really was so attentive and he'd come in
and hold my hand in between takes and um
it was it was a wonderful experience the
the role was really really hard to do
and really uh i really just wanted to do
it right and it definitely took an
emotional toll but i um i think i'm
gonna be really proud of it and uh i
trust taylor's writing i trust the
people also in the edit for me it was
really hard to like let go of the lack
of
involvement i have in post production
but knowing and hearing things about the
p they're using the same people from
from yellowstone and they've there's a
team of people that actually care about
the show it's not just another show
that's just being churned out and
everyone involved is really really cares
about it and so you as an actor i i mean
i'm able to put my trust in those guys
and and know that it's gonna they're
gonna show the best of what i was able
to do on set um but it was i felt safe
and comfortable and just also just to be
amongst these people was an absolute
privilege
and we hear milo call for iris to come
play a part in whatever he clearly has
going on so who is she to him what can
you say about their connectionist
characters
um
iris would be one of
any number of people
you know um
milo is connected with uh or that is in
command of or whatever who would
have different
skills or
disciplines or you know
ways to go about things but uh
we wouldn't even particularly know each
other that well you know because
iris is so young i've been in prison you
know but
um but milo is totally totally on top of
what's going on you know it's in a way
to run things from behind bars you've
got nothing else to do
you know so you've got all day long and
all months long to kind of you know
um put your get your pieces in place
um
we we hopefully we'll see more of you
know what the connection is between
these two but it's it's quite a
and definitely a dark bond
um
i think
she's also smart she's also i know she's
smart though
i know that yes you know because you
don't want to send get the get the wrong
person it's it's not just let's uh call
anybody in to do this and it's
you know
we're talking about dirty dangerous
um
work here and it's not your best work
well milo can call it work
um
but you know you can you got to be very
careful and i think that's that's part
of milo's uh genius in his recruitment
uh
process is
you know getting the right desperate
people who are also really clever
yeah it's i love a good character study
and these characters are seem endlessly
fascinating so thank you for talking to
me about them
thanks
you